bonjour noté l'insee merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors on
vient de me dire le parlement européen a
entériné l'accord commercial de l'union
européenne avec le royaume uni un accord
qui avait été conclu in extremis en
décembre dernier ils étaient appliquées
de manière provisoire dans les grandes
lignes
qu'est ce qu'il prévoit cet accord alors
pour l'essentiel c'est-à-dire le
commerçant fait des marchandises et bien
on va continuer vers une libre
circulation donc ça veut dire qu'il n'ya
pas de tarifs douaniers qui t'impose est
pour continuer en fait c'est échanger
pour pénaliser en fait aucun aucun des
deux partenaires est là la seule
différence c'est qu'effectivement j'ai
produit qui sont échangées en fait entre
les pays doivent respecter les normes
par exemple en vigueur en europe
donc même si ça a l'air très simple on a
l'air juste de continuer ce qu'on
faisait avant le diarra est toujours
dans les détails
et c'est justement l'ordre parce qu'il
faut respecter les normes que finalement
ce sera peut-être plus compliqué qu'on
le pense dans certaines dans certaines
circonstances
concrètement qu'est-ce que cela va
changer du point de vue du royaume uni
est le royaume uni pas continuer à
pouvoir exporter à porter comme il veut
comme vous d'ailleurs en europe avec
avec le royaume uni
il n'y a pas de différence en fait dans
le lait la facilité des échanges serrés
pas de droits de douane on n'a pas de
paperasserie et particulière à faire
néanmoins puisque ce sont des produits
échangés devront
respectivement respecter les normes de
chacun des deux pays donc comme en
surtout en fait pour le royaume uni de
lorsqu ils exportent et bien faudra que
ces produits soient aux normes de deux
lieux parce qu'ils sont pour le moment
mais devant donc en gros continuer à
l'être
alors on sait que les relations entre
londres et bruxelles ont été
profondément affecté par la décision
britannique de quitter justement le
marché unique comment est ce que vous
voyez
l'évolution du commerce entre les états
membres et le royaume uni du point de
vue du commerce pour le moment il n'y a
pas à l'heure guillaud on constate on a
constaté depuis janvier en effet quand
même une baisse en fait de ce commerce
au niveau à la fois les exportations et
des importations on a eu une baisse des
exportations européennes constatée
depuis mois de janvier de 20 % avec des
importations de 2 47%
néanmoins il n'était pas non plus à
imputer totalement aubrée xi enfin on
fait qu'on est en train de se normaliser
les relations y avait aussi le comité
qui ne facilitait pas non plus les
échanges avec les restrictions avec le
royaume uni de toute façon mais bien sûr
il va y avoir parce que de lille va y
avoir des ajustements il ya un temps de
comme je vous ai dit de de mise en place
étant donné que même si sur le papier on
a toujours un commerce relativement
libre le fait que l'on n'ait à être
certain que les normes soient bien
respectées ça fera un parti en fait des
ajustements possibles
par ailleurs il ya des points
effectivement d'achoppement qui sont qui
reste en fait la pêche on a regardé
condé un accord qui a été conclu mais en
fait quand vous avez les sans doute
relayé plus plus tôt dans le mois
d'avril il ya eu quelques tensions
puisqu'en fait il
britannique met du temps à donner des
licences en fait qui autorise les
pêcheurs français par exemple aller
pêcher dans les eaux britanniques
sachent les eaux britanniques sont
riches en poissons donc ça c'est
effectivement un problème
l'autre problème aussi qui a été
soulevée s'il le fait que dans l'accord
un point important était celui avec le
commerce avec la partie aval entre les
deux irlande et en irlande du nord et on
était arrivé sur une situation où en
fait pendant une certaine période on
aurait pas de contrôles dont il aurait
pas de frontières imposées mais
néanmoins des contrôles et boris johnson
a donc décidé de pour repousser ces
contrôles pour d'un au mois d'octobre
c'est donc qui s'est donné six mois de
plus donc ça évidemment ça n'a pas
beaucoup plus non plus aux européens et
puis l'autre dossier qui n'est pas clos
avec cet accord entériné par le
parlement c'est le dossier financier
puisque en fait pour le moment les
services financiers ne font pas partie
de l'accord évidemment pour la grande
bretagne là par contre c'est un enjeu
important puisqu'elle est elle à une
place-forte niveau sa place est
importante au niveau financier
et d'ailleurs la france sur le volet de
la pêche a déclaré il ya quelques jours
aussi la l'angleterre n'obtempérait pas
eh bien le prendrait des mesures de
rétorsion sur les services financiers
dernière question concernant les vaccins
le vaccin astrazeneca on sait que
londres et les européens se traite de
plus en plus de manière
en rivaux on va dire concernant
justement cette question des vaccins
puisque ils ont été livrés beaucoup plus
vite au royaume uni est ce que là aussi
on peut imaginer des tensions entre les
vingt-sept et londres oui facile
malheureusement oui ça fait partie
fallait vaccins font partie de tension
parce que il ya une urgence à ce que les
différents pays européens puissent se
faire vacciner rapidement donc bien
évidemment on a on aime on n'apprécie
guère voir un pays livré plus rapidement
par rapport à ceux qui attendent aussi
néanmoins la stratégie sans doute de
longs délais boris johnson s'était
beaucoup plus clair et il est comme pour
l'israël israël il était près à
effectivement mettre tous les moyens en
oeuvre pour s'assurer de de
l'approvisionnement du vaccin très
rapidement pour pouvoir vacciner le plus
vite possible aux populations les autres
pays européens peut-être pêché par par
le manque de détermination par rapport à
cet objectif
merci beaucoup en tout cas de nathalie
chanson d'avoir répondu à nos questions
il se rappelle que vous êtes professeur
d'économie et de finance